so we're going to talk about realtime
machine learning and show you a
framework that's going to allow you to
take any new or existing machine
learning model and turn it into a
real-time machine learning model which
basically means a model that you can
dynamically retrain dynamically tune on
a very frequent basis without increasing
the uh the cost of doing
so um so just before we we talk about
that uh a recent paper from MIT Harvard
University of montree and Cambridge uh
did a very thorough evaluation of model
degradation uh and the results at least
are intuitive uh to many data scientists
is that almost all of the models degrade
in time some of them degrade faster some
of them slower a lot of this has to do
with the data uh some of it has to do
with the algorithm or network on which
it was trained uh but models uh degrade
fairly fairly quickly and a result as a
result of that have to be
retrained um we actually took took uh
one of the data sets that they used in
that uh in that paper uh this one was a
flight delay data set and we did
something very simple we we trained the
initial model on it and then uh
predicted 26 weeks out uh and we're
looking at the accuracy of the model
here and kind of as you'd expect the the
accuracy of the model starts declining
or deteriorating uh as you move along as
you get further away from the last data
that was it was trained on um and the
expectation is if you would be training
more frequently uh you could be able
you'd be able to maintain this accuracy
um so what we did is we switched this to
uh to weekly retraining uh and the
results uh were not only that we were
able to maintain accuracy we're actually
able to improve our accuracy um so over
this 26 week period our average accuracy
increased by just over 11% and our F1
score increased by over 20% so the
benefit of retraining is not only uh
making sure your model doesn't
deteriorate in in in in terms of its
quality it's also improving the quality
because you have new data you have more
data coming in uh to train your
model um sometimes weekly retraining is
not enough uh this is a paper from uh
from GrubHub uh that were published uh
and they tell about their experience
taking their recommendation uh system uh
which would make recommendations in the
app on what
restaurants uh to order from uh and they
talk about moving it from you know from
no retraining which their which was
their Baseline to weekly retraining and
to daily retraining and by moving from
no retraining to weekly retraining they
were able to only improve their purchase
through rate by two and a half percent
but moving to daily retraining improved
by over 20% from the Baseline uh so in
this case the data moves so fast the
data changes so fast that Weekly
retraining just wasn't enough they
actually needed daily
retraining so
whether it you know whether it's daily
or weekly or or hourly or or monthly
that would depend on the model depend on
on the data um but what we see from uh
from from uh from a lot of models is
that the importance of of retraining is
very significant so why don't we do it
more often right there's challenges the
first one is lack of automation if you
have to do this manually every time if
there's no automated pipeline this is
going to be a lot of work and you don't
have time to do this every day um then
there's the C in time of computing
people uh if you have a large data set
or maybe if if it even isn't large but
you're doing a lot of uh you're testing
a lot of hyperparameter combinations
this can take a long time and and can
cost a lot of money uh and finally
there's approval processes uh that you
may have to go through that will slow
down the ability to uh to update your
your
model so what we're going to be doing
today is basically looking at this
framework from data Heroes uh for
automated real-time machine learning uh
which addresses all of these issues uh
and there's a few principles to this
framework the first one is fully
automated retraining with a high
retraining frequency if you're
retraining at a high frequency it has to
be fully automated uh there's no way
that you can manually do this uh it also
means that you have to limit the type of
retraining that you do you you're not
you know you don't you're not going to
be doing feature engineering uh you're
just going to be updating updating the
model with new data as the new data uh
comes in so just literally retraining
with new data
the second principle is that you want to
retrain not just with the new data but
also with your old data so that you're
avoiding
bias uh the third is you want to be able
to evaluate multiple date ranges because
depending again depending on the model
depending on how the data changes
sometimes you're going to get the best
model by retraining on just the most
recent data or maybe a longer period of
time uh and that could really vary and
really could change based on the drift
in the data so you have to be able to
evalate multiple date ranges um the next
one is the ability to tune to find the
best hyperparameters because the right
hyper parameters can make a significant
difference um and since uh this uh this
framework in this framework you're
training with new data you're not
actually changing features uh the
approval processes may be unnecessary uh
because the changes are lightweight they
just date range changes to to to the
data um and then from time to time you
would want to do a more elaborate manual
update uh that may include feature
engineering maybe try out different
algorithms different models uh but
that's something that you're not going
to be doing on a frequent
basis so how do we do all this without
increasing our compute costs uh
significantly so um we're going to uh
present now the uh the data Heroes
realtime machine learning framework uh
basically what it is is it's taking your
data set and converting it to a data
Heroes data structure you do that with
the free data hero Library which allows
you to convert to the uh data Heroes
data structure and then all uh all
training retraining tuning is enabled
significantly Faster by using this data
structure and significantly cheaper and
and we'll see how and we'll talk about
that um but first and foremost uh let's
start by explaining this this data
structure so we have our data instances
uh on the bottom X1 through x21 that's
your training data set um you have a
function in the library called build
which basically build uh the builds the
data structure it's fully automated and
once you call build a few things happen
the first thing that happens is that the
data set is partitioned into chunks uh
the partition may depend on a lot of
different things the size of the chunks
may depend on how much memory you have
Etc I'm not going to go into that right
now but the data is partitioned into
chunks the next thing we do is we take
every chunk and we compute a
representative sample uh for each chunk
what does that mean we take the data
from X1 through X6 and we compute uh
something called a coret which is a
representative weighted sample of the
data from X1 through X6 which basically
means it's a selection of a few samples
from the from that data set with weights
assigned to them that represents that
piece of data so if you train your model
on X1 through X6 or if you train your
model on what we call C1 our core set
here you would get the same or almost
the same model um and we're going to
explain a little bit more about corsets
in a few slides so let's just take that
as a given right now this coret thing uh
and assume that we're creating this
coret we're calculating this coret from
each chunk of data and each coret
represents statistically represents the
data that's uh that's under it the next
thing we do is we take every pair of
corsets and we compute the new coret for
them so C3 is a coret of C1 and C2 and
actually represents our data from X1
through
X12 and so on until we get to our root
so that's how the tree in is constructed
that's part of calling that build
function that would construct this uh
this coret tree for you now there's a
few uh attributes that this corset tree
has the first one it's infinitely
scalable it's distributed uh even
geographically which means you can
partition doesn't matter how big your
data set is you can partition it into
chunks and and build this tree even
distributed across uh different
instances uh even across different uh
geographical locations so if you have if
you're collecting data from different
geographical locations you don't
actually have to bring all the data into
to one location to train on it you can
create a core set of the data in each
one of those locations and just send the
C the the the coret over to a cental
location for this tree to be
built um the second uh uh uh attribute
of this is that the tree can be built
based on a business logic uh for example
time series so if your data is time
series data um then you know for example
C1 the course at C1 that represents X1
through X6 might be week one of your
data and C2 might be week two and so on
and so forth um and what does that give
us well that's the next bullet point um
your model can be trained on any cor at
industry so if you want to train your
model on your full data set you're going
to train on the root which is C7 in this
case but if you want to train on a
portion let's say on week one or week
two of your data or week two or week and
week three you can uh train it on any
core set or or combination of core sets
within your
tree um the other attribute is that the
data structure is built once but can be
used multiple times so once you build it
you never have to actually rebuild it uh
again um and and we'll talk about that
again in a minute
um and finally the time it takes to
build this this pre-processing phase is
less than the time it would take to
train on this model many times even
significantly less even orders of
magnitude less than than training on the
model so you may be asking yourself well
this is great but how does this help me
retrain my model in production um and
the answer is um in production you're
going to have a model that's initially
trained on a training data set uh and
then going to have more data coming in
every day or every hour or whatever the
frequency might be um with this
structure you never actually have to
rebuild the the structure from scratch
what you can do with new data from
production comes in you can simply add
it to the existing structure so if I now
have I collected new data x22 through
x24 I can simply add it to an existing
node I have a function in the library
that does that it's called partial build
this whole process is automated it it's
added to a node as a result of that the
core four sets on the path to the root
will get updated so C5 will get updated
C6 and C7 and this process takes a few
seconds and I now have an updated uh uh
tree that I can train on um which
includes both my old and my new
data uh the same applies by the way if I
need to change data if I need to modify
a label or remove data the exact same
process takes a few seconds I never have
to actually retrain on my full data
set um so let's see an a real example of
this uh here what we have is we have a
data set and uh we're doing kind of
similar to what would happen in
production we're training a model with a
a part of the data set and then we're
adding more and more data and retraining
our model we're doing it once with the
full data set and once we're doing it by
using the data here's Library so um
let's look at the full data set first uh
we take the first two million instances
and we train it takes us 335 seconds to
do that uh then we add another 4 million
in retrain another 4 million in retrain
and another 4 million in retrain and
finally when we're at 14 million
instances uh it takes us 1,850 seconds
uh to train so about half an hour to
train and of course as more data is
collected this is going to continue
growing now we do the same by using the
the data here is Library first what we
do is we take those first two million
and we build that data Heroes data
structure the time at takes to build the
data Hero's data structure is 8 seconds
compare that to the 335 seconds it took
to train just 8 seconds to build the uh
the data structure and then training on
the data structure uh we're actually
training on that coret of the root coret
takes just 18 seconds because we're
training on significantly less data only
data that is in in that core set um and
then what we're doing is we're adding
200,000 instances uh to our uh uh
structure at a time and it takes us 4
seconds to add 200,000 instances so
imagine you have data coming from
production and every hour or every day
you're adding another 200,000 instances
it's just four seconds to add um and you
can see that even as we keep doing that
the time it takes to add the instances
and retrain stays pretty much the same
which is around uh 28 seconds so this
doesn't grow uh the way that the
training time will grow as your data set
grows because it has a street structure
it grows logarithmically it would grow
significantly slower and the bigger the
data set the more uh benefit you will
see
here um I'm gonna I'm going to do a
quick pause to see if there's any
questions aan that you want to answer
that we're asked in the meantime before
we we talk a little bit more in detail
about what coures
are uh actually I think I'm covering
those uh pretty good on the on the chat
over here uh there is one thing that
address you said that uh there was no
feat feature engineering needed uh the
idea is that you not need to reinvent
and do Fe enging from scratch you can
take your exective pipeline in order to
to do
that yeah thank
you okay so let's take a little uh a
little bit of a look at what that what
this coret thing is so um a coret
basically comes from the field of
computational geometry uh it's been
studied in Academia for the past 20
years it's based on mathematical proofs
um and what it is basically a corset is
a small weighted subset from a data set
that preserves the statistical
properties and the outliers of the data
set with respect to a given algorithm um
that means it's not like a reduction of
it's not a dimensionality reduction like
PCA uh we're taking actual instances
from the original data set and we're
giving them a
weight um and once we create this core
set you can do training you can do
tuning on the coret and you get the same
or almost the same result as if you've
used the underlying data that was used
to create the core set uh the magic
behind the computation of a coret is a
value called
sensitivity um we compute sensitivity
value for every uh instance in the
original data set and what the
sensitivity tells us is basically it
tells us how much this uh the mod will
be affected uh by this individual
instance it's kind of like uh doing
leave one out kind of uh you know you
how would the model be affected if I
removed this instance from my training
data set but leave on out is very very
heavy expensive in terms of compute and
this sensitivity calculation is very
very light uh but it does tell us
exactly how much each instance affects
our model so once we can compute the
sensitivity what we do is we take the
instances with the high High sensitivity
because those are usually our outliers
they have individually they have a high
effect on the model so we take the the
ones with the high sensitivity and we
include them in the core sets in the
core set um and the instances with the
low sensitivity are usually our normal
distribution so each one individually
that doesn't have a lot of effect on the
model or any because there's a lot of
others like it so we just take a a small
sample of those and give him a bigger
weight a larger weight to represent
their repetition in the full data set so
that's how uh the core set is is
built um let's take a look at a couple
of of uh a couple more case studies and
then jump to the library uh so this one
uh is a case study of patient weight
times a model for patient weight times
with XG boost uh and what we could see
is the the Baseline here is quarterly
retraining uh by moving to monthly
retraining we were able to improve
accuracy by by
2.7% but the real benefit came from uh
by moving to weak we l retraining uh by
moving to weekly retraining uh we were
able to improve accuracy by
10% um if you look at their actual
compute costs since we we're using that
data Hero's data structure we're using
the core sets uh so we're training on
significantly smaller uh data to do that
uh by moving to monthly retraining we
were able to save 82% of the compute
costs and moving to weekly retraining
saved us 22% of the compute cost so you
could you know you get to have your cake
and eat it too you're improving accuracy
and you're reducing
cost um the second example uh this is a
fraud protection data set the light GBM
model uh and here uh this focuses on
hyperparameter tuning so this client uh
does a lot of hyperparameter tuning uh
in fact they uh they evaluate 104 144
hyperparameters it takes them 154 hours
to do so that's about 6 and a half
days um by switching to the data hero is
data structure they were able to lower
this to just five hours for
hyperparameter
tuning um and because it was uh uh uh so
so much faster to do it they actually
decided to expand their hyperparameter
search uh and moved up to 864 hyp
parameters which increased their time to
30 hours but still significantly less uh
than the
154 and the bottom line is the accuracy
of their model which would what you
could see at the bottom they went from
0o
886 to a 0.94 accuracy for their model
uh by switching to data Heroes and using
the uh the the larger number of hyper
parameters now the other thing that you
might notice here is this uh this graph
in the middle which shows that uh the
same number of hyperparameters 144 by
using data Heroes they actually were
able to get a a better balanced accuracy
score than they were able to get from
the full data set um which we've seen
happen many times uh there's a lot of
different uh quality metrics um and
we've seen some of them uh we are able
to achieve significantly better results
uh some of them are you know not always
better uh some of them slightly less uh
so results could vary depending on on on
the data set but it's been many times
that we've been able to surpass uh the
results from the full data
set
so finally to get started um you can
visit our website datah heroes. if you
go to the uh um uh the menu on top
resources and choose the getting started
page that basically allows you to create
a free account once you create a free
account uh you can pip install the
library pip install it uh anywhere on
your own machine you could do that uh
and activate your account and start
using the library uh you can do it on on
your own computer which means you know
you're your data set never actually has
has to leave your uh your uh your
environment um we also have the code
wizard which is very helpful in terms of
helping you get uh get
started um let me quickly show you the
the code wizard so the idea with the
codes code wizard is that you're able to
select uh the type of use case uh
whether you're doing model training and
tuning or model retraining uh you can
select the your Elmo algorithm uh the
library that you want uh how your data
set is available whether it's a
nump uh or whether it's a data frame or
whether it's a file the type of file Etc
uh and the code is automatically
generated for you just to make it easier
to to start uh and you just have to
replace uh those yellow highlights with
with their you know your relevant data
um so that makes it significantly easier
to start uh and just to give you a quick
g a quick glimpse of how um how it's
done in order to build a coret what you
need to do is you first initialize the
the object
uh in this case we're initializing an
object called corset Tree Service DTC
DTC is decision tree classification
because we're going to be doing a
decision tree classification model um
you pass a few parameters to uh to the
core set um and then uh after you've
initialized the object you basically
called the build or build from file uh
and that will build that street tree
structure you've seen uh so it's really
really easy um and then for example in
this example if you you want to add data
new data that came in from production
you use the partial build from file uh
and this would add your data to the
existing uh existing tree that you've
already
created um so it's very simple to start
using um that's it um we have uh you
know you're welcome to to visit our
website our GitHub our LinkedIn uh reach
out to us if there's any questions just
use the contact form uh or feel free to
email me my email is or o
Ren datah heroes. AI we we'd love to
hear from you uh and at this point I'm
going to stop sharing and uh open up to
any additional
questions Orin and aan thanks so much
that was a great talk so and thanks so
much for answering all those questions
that was a good uh Team talk there for
sure
so just give it a few more minutes there
to see if some more comments come in
but great hey are there any questions
that uh you want to answer no I think
you cover it all uh I I was I didn't
follow everything you said I was busy
here answering people not seeing
anything open that
uh really cool no I think I got
ill okay I think so
too all right
okay um great well if there's no more
questions we're we're happy to give
every everyone four minutes back of
their time thank you so much um there's
a new question just came in uh could you
expand a bit more on the course at
having a
sensitivity with respect to a certain
algorithm uh by that do you mean a
classifi
algorithm yeah so so the answer is it's
not one core set that works for any
algorithm a core set needs to be built
for a particular algorithm so there's a
coret for linear regression and one for
logistic regression and one for decision
tree classification problems which
includes um you know gradient boosting
Etc and one for decisionally regressing
and one for deep learning Etc um that's
what that's what we mean by that and you
notice when we when I initialize I show
how we initialize the library we have to
actually select which type of core set
we want to build based on the problem
that we're trying to solve and if we're
planning to train a few different models
uh in some cases you might want to build
a few different core
sets
yeah follow question are you seeing the
question Z
yeah yeah do you understand
it yeah he's following up on the
question if you need to know had to
classify the algorithm so yeah at at the
moment you need to know ahead what
you're going to use I would mention that
the bill times is so fast that you can
try various uh uh algorithms even though
uh there each one of them is independent
and you can and you cannot uh you cannot
switch you cannot start using a a
decision tree then say no I want to
switch back to logistic regression you
need to stick with what you chose but
you can build both of them the build
time for those are very quick but but
I'll add to that that all the decision
tree problems uh use the same this the
same family they use the same core set
so if you're planning to do random
forest and grad and boosting or XG boost
and light GBM you're actually using the
same core set for all of those so you
need to to build that course at
once yeah there there's another question
about uh uh if we can use another
Library actually uh you can you can
choose uh uh the let's call the backbone
of which kind of uh Library you're going
to choose if you want to cat boost or ex
boost or IBM you can choose the the
backbone over it for it for the
classification part
itself or secondy learn oh Cy learn of
course